So Richard just showed you
some of the flaws with HTTP/1,
and said that HTTP/2
would solve them.
But how does it do it?
Well, take out your
note-taking pencil,
because I'm about to show
you the wonders of HTTP/2.
Remember the human readability
of requests and response
headers?
Well, that's got to go.
It's the first step to improve
performance with HTTP/2.
It was nice while it
lasted, but nobody is really
benefiting from the plain text
approach that HTTP/1 took.
We are wasting precious
bytes by spelling things out
in text form when a
single bit is sufficient.
Don't worry, though.
Tools like Wireshark
or DevTools will still
let you see headers,
even with HTTP/2.
The second big
problem HTTP/2 solves
is head-of-line blocking.
It does this through a
technique called multiplexing.
Multiplexing is a
fancy sounding term
that means combining
multiple signals
into a new single signal.
With HTTP/2, we now have one
connection instead of six.
That seems like a terrible
step backwards at first,
but we are using the single
connection differently
than HTTP/1 would have.
What used to be a dedicated
connection in HTTP/1
is now called a
stream, and all streams
share that single connection.
These streams are
split up into frames
and are being multiplexed
onto that single connection.
When one stream is
blocked, another stream
can take over the connection
and make good use of what
would have been idle time.
Head-of-line blocking, be gone.
Lastly, HTTP/2 takes care of
header data being uncompressed.
With HTTP/2,
headers are not just
being compressed with
[? key.zip, ?] the engineers
came up with an HTTP/2
compression that
is tailored towards the
specific structure of headers
and the multiplexing
feature of HTTP/2.
All streams not only share
the connection, but also
the compressor.
This means a header never
has to be sent twice,
since the compressor recognizes
that it's been sent before,
and sends a reference instead.
For example, cookies
are really long headers.
So it is an enormous
advantage to say,
insert the same cookie
header as three requests ago
here, instead of
the actual value.
I won't go into the intricacies
of this compression algorithm.
But if you're interested
in how it works,
there is some additional
reading in the instructor notes.